this luck your slang name I mean I like
it's an amazing color on you
okay so years ago I was interviewing
Sophia Lillis and I said who do you want
to play your adult counterpart and
without skipping a beat she said Jessica
Chastain I would pick I love that girl
she's the best so how long did you know
I mean how long did you know that you
were playing her was this years did she
have any inkling at that time you know
when they were making the first movie
and he sent me a picture it was like a
side-by-side of her and me and he just
wrote what do you think and I was like I
see your your plans I always listened
with the second he asked me to do it I
knew I was going to do it I just wanted
to play hard to get a little bit so I
did and I was very happy to to be it
you've been prepping your entire life
for this role as we saw in your clown
throwback Instagram photo I know I've
been at all of us have an inner clown
inside of us I'm not afraid of clowns
and maybe it's because it was one of my
first Halloween costumes I was gonna
play this whole press don't get probably
people are probably like are you afraid
of clowns you're like no afraid at all
I dreamt of you
[Music]
what was that experience like is that
harder than a filming the actual no it's
just funny because you know I've done
two horror films with Andy and I did
crimson Pekin and doing ADR for the
horror genre is a very funny thing
because there's a lot of screaming and
grunting and making noises
neither lots and lots of honey a lot a
lot of team